this is a California roll and it was
probably invented in Japan wrong-o
California nope it was invented in
Canada this is chef Tojo right
hi mrs. Schaeffer Joe he held to make
sushi one of the most popular foods in
the US and Canada but to understand this
we have to take a look back it was 1971
and sushi wasn't popular when it came to
Japanese food people only liked a couple
things just people eat eat tempura and
also teriyaki turns out North Americans
they did not like seaweed no no no way
look terrible they said some people yeah
do you know so Tojo did something crazy
he wrapped the rice on the outside of
the ceiling to hide it in Japan people
they passing me well this is a long idea
wrong idea but people like it and chef
Tojo he did not stop there okay
everybody eat cucumber avocado and
cooked crab just a change this
preparation just low so he rolled these
preferred ingredients into one beautiful
amazing cuisine changing roll I didn't
call to California Lord we called inside
uncle where it is it got the name
California roll because it was so
popular with people who came to his
restaurant from LA and the roll made
people think differently about sushi it
was some sort of gateway roll people
starting with California law oh this is
very good then smoked salmon and tuna
step by step they love it
chef Tojo's beginner roll was such a
success Japan's Ministry of Agriculture
Forestry and Fisheries appointed him as
the nation's goodwill ambassador for
Japanese cuisine and now sushi is
everywhere stickers on your notebook USB
drives play-doh molds wooden toys sets
everywhere maybe not all thanks to chef
Tojo but definitely partly
[Music]